[Musique]
on est aux abords de l'autoroute 10 fin
de l'hiver 2010 est des dizaines de
véhicules sont déjà encastrés les uns
dans les autres
il n'y aura finalement aucun blessé
grave
comme ici en ontario quelques semaines
avant
c'est toujours l'hiver qu'ont lieu les
carambolages les plus impressionnants
l'intéressé il y en a qui roulent trop
il se hisse trop proche
picasa cac safran n'ont juste pas le
temps de réagir ça soit au delà de ça
c'était près de val alain sur
l'autoroute 20 c'était déneiger mais je
pensais de la glace noire dont il aurait
peut-être fallu du sel ou autre
effectivement le rapport conclura que
les camions d'épandage sont sortis trop
tard mais ce qui a surtout retenu
l'attention l'année dernière c'est cet
accident sur l'autoroute 40
parce qu'il est survenu au même endroit
ou presque que celui de 2006 un blizzard
soudain sur l'autoroute un père et sa
fille avaient été tués déjà sont apposés
pourtant pour pas que ça se reproduise
encore une troisième fois la et ses
gestes cela faisait plus d'une décennie
qu'ils avaient été identifiés par le
coroner de l'époque la façon aussi mme
d'arrêter ça c'est pas compliqué c'est
maître d armes qui vont couper le vin
qu'ils les rafales de neige
c'est ce que j'avais recommandé et ça
n'a pas été fait jack système aurifère
et de la négligence
les arbres ont commencé à être plantés
cet automne par le ministre des
transports lui même lui dont le discours
n'a pas changé depuis l'année dernière
je veux pas materner les gens j'aime pas
materner les jeunes mais dit il il
faudrait quand même qu'ils adaptent leur
conduite dans les conditions hivernales
[Musique]
ici mathieu prost radio canada montréal